Okay, I said I was gonna make videos
talking about how to not be anti Semitic
when you are trying to support Palestinian liberation.
So this is video one.
I would like to preface this that I am not an expert in this.
I am just a Jewish person.
That's it. Those are my credentials.
But something I've noticed that people are doing
are going to random Jewish creators pages
on completely unrelated videos.
Or even worse,
if they're specifically talking about a Jewish religious practice,
like what they're making for Shabbat dinner
and commenting on those videos like, well,
what do you feel about Israel?
How do you feel about Palestine?
That feels and comes off pretty anti Semitic and attacky really,
cause you're only doing it because they're Jewish.
Even someone like me
who has posted pro Palestinian content
and nuanced content about everything going on,
I still get like
the nervousness to share anything about my Jewishness right now
because it's going to be met with anti Zionist activists.
That doesn't come off as well meaning activism.
It comes off as disguised anti Semitism,
which is not the intention.